jay-z
involved with the nfl and this is very
confusing they made a big deal about
this yesterday jay-z's firm roc nation
is going to help produce the super bowl
halftime show they're going to be
involved in identifying and producing
new music for the nfl like the nfl is
becoming a music producer kind of a
bizarre situation also there's a sense
that there's going to be involvement
with jay-z and social justice
initiatives by the nfl and i i saw this
yesterday chris and i took a step back
because jay-z has been a vocal supporter
of colin kaepernick
how does jay-z
do a deal with the nfl considering what
the nfl has been doing to colin
kaepernick and does jay-z only do that
deal with the nfl if he's gotten some
sort of assurance that the cold shoulder
of colin kaepernick may soon be coming
to an end well
he's been very supportive you're right
of the colin kaepernick situation i mean
ultimately i think what got this done
was money i mean let's just be real
about that but that doesn't mean jay-z
doesn't have great care for some of the
social issues that are going on in our
country and i i kind of take it like
this i'm with you at first i went oh he
did a deal i was shocked because because
of what you know has been out there
about kaepernick and all those things
but at the same time maybe he this is a
smart guy jay-z greatest rapper of all
time uh and
i think he's looking at it going yeah
it's messed up with colin kaepernick and
i'm not necessarily in love with being
in business with you guys with how you
treated them but i think there's also
you know the wherewithal to go
maybe i can help stop some of this stuff
in the future and we can grow as a
country a league everything and just
become better from it in that aspect i
do respect it and you know the quote
that jay-z put out there that's where i
think it turned me a little bit because
that led me to believe he's he's looking
to change the culture in sports the
world how we view things you know like
we were just talking about you know shut
up and dribble shut up and play sports
okay uh but you know rich white man nope
don't shut up we'd love to hear what you
say you know and i'm just i'm sick of
that and you know i'm hoping jc is just
going to help that conversation make
players feel better open the eyes of
people in the nfl to what's really going
on in the hood and some of the poorer
countries are poor places in our country
where african-americans are going
through some big time struggles
i know that i read the same quote you
did i read the quote from jay-z the
quote from commissioner roger goodell
and to me those words ring hollow
as you continue to screw colin
kaepernick if we believe that he's being
screwed and i think we do i think honest
fair-minded people who can set aside
their intense dislike of colin
kaepernick because they can't separate a
protest that happens during the national
anthem from the concept that he is
protesting the national anthem um i i
think that you you you just you can't
continue to freeze this guy out and
embrace the very lessons and concepts
and principles he is trying to promote
and if i'm jay-z now look i don't want
to tell jay-z how to do his business
he's been more successful than i'll ever
be if i'd live to be a million years old
but but
i find it hard to believe that he would
sign off on an arrangement with the nfl
unless the nfl
has made it clear to him that they are
in the process of getting colin
kaepernick back into the national
football league in some capacity and uh
uh it's it's it's it's a tough tight
rope to walk without colin kaepernick
re-embraced by the nfl and i'm maybe
it's part of me just holding out hope
that we get to see the guy on the
football field again no we've been
robbed for three years of his talents
and abilities we saw him for a couple of
years with crappy 49ers teams where it
was impossible for him to play like he
did in 2012 and 2013. the guy still has
something to offer and uh i i just i i
the voice you know stick to sports no
we're gonna keep saying this guy got
screwed he got screwed and uh he
continues to get screwed it's it's not
ending just because they settled his
collusion grievance whether they're
retaliating against him because of the
collusion grievance or they're still
showing him who's boss because he made
the other players aware of their rights
under the anthem policy i believe
they're still screwing him chris and all
the excuses out there are just bs yeah
i'm with you mike i i i they are
screwing them i don't even i don't think
you can even look at it in any other way
he's certainly worthy of you know he was
worthy of being a starting quarterback
certainly worthy of being a backup
quarterback i mean you know to say he
wasn't one of the best 64 quarterbacks
in the world is
absolutely
insane uh but you know i just don't know
if one particular owner is going to want
to deal with it like we've said and i
just think jay-z who's very smart i
think is probably just looking at this
going okay yeah you know he he probably
understands that people are going to
look at him the way you're saying as a
little hollow but i think also he's got
a bigger picture in mind to go
let's not let this happen again and i
think that's where where you know i'm
trying to be positive about it i think
that's where he's at because he's he's
shown me some positive things along
these these kind of conversations before
ah i think it's a net positive
development there's just a caveat
there's an asterisk there's a there's a
blemish on this
because everything that they want to
promote
runs contrary to the idea that colin
kaepernick is being frozen out of the
league on false pretenses all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports